[Música]
dicen mis alumnos que como profeso y muy
buen cuentacuentos entonces es justo lo
que voy a hacer el día de hoy te voy a
contar dos historias que no forman parte
de mi vida te voy a contar dos historias
que son mi vida que son mi vida la
primera de ellas comienza un 9 de agosto
de 1994 con mi mamá en una sala de parto
llena de sudor y hoy llegando al mundo
lleno de placenta y apestando ya no
estoy lleno de placenta pero si va
apestando si no me creen pregúntenle a
mi ex pero él
desde que llegó al mundo me fascina la
idea de aprender de experimentar la vida
de conocer el mundo me fascina esa idea
desde muy chiquito comienzo a aprender
lo más que pueda era una persona a la
que le fascinaba el conocimiento
cuanto más pudiera aprender más feliz
era más feliz era y así va pasando mi
tiempo desde mi infancia hasta el día de
hoy dicen que hay una etapa del porque
yo creo que no es una etapa en mi caso
yo creo que es mi vida el por qué y
resulta que desde muy temprana edad yo
creo que desde que aprendí a decirlo
porque empecé a preguntar por qué por
qué por qué pero resulta que a la mayor
parte de las preguntas que hacía no se
les tenía una respuesta entonces en mi
cuarto había un sillón rojo
había un sillón rojo donde pasaba horas
me sentaba en ese sillón y empezaba a
pensar el porqué de las cosas un proceso
de metacognición interesantísimo para un
niño de 4 o 5 años finalmente este
proceso de tres horas de metacognición
terminaba en horas de vómito si pensaba
tanto que terminaba con un dolor de
cabeza
terrible entonces llega el momento en el
que por fin puedo acudir a una escuela
al kínder y resulta que era un lugar
donde se hacen atendía a esta necesidad
que yo tenía de aprender porque una
necesidad de ocupación por fin podía ir
a un lugar donde podía aprender
para mí era un lugar sagrado y también
para mis papás porque aún cuando
estuviera bien enfermo me llevaban a
fuerzas al kinder entonces tuve que
agarrar le gusto sí o sí
fue pasando el tiempo y llegué a la
primaria
en la primaria ocurrió algo
extraordinario aprendí a leer fue
extraordinario para mí no para mi
familia sí porque íbamos en el carril o
iba leyendo cada uno de los letreros
verde
[Música]
come frutas y verduras
hasta que se hartan si ya sabemos que
aprendiste a leer lepe si ya nos dimos
cuenta a todos que ya sabes leer y así
era cuando aprendo a leer
hay algo que se vuelve alguien que se
vuelve mi mejor amigo era un pequeño era
un pequeño muy famoso quizá este los de
generaciones más viejitas lo conozcan
les pregunto siempre las nuevas
generaciones y dicen que no lo conocen
este pequeño era una muy buena
influencia según decían mis profesores
según decía mi familia este pequeño se
llamaba el pequeño larousse diccionario
enciclopédico era genial era genial
porque yo saliendo de la escuela llegaba
abría el pequeño larousse y entonces
empezaba a llenarme de palabras
interesantísimas geniales y al final del
día podía llegar con mi hermano y jugar
a basta y ganarle si esa era la
motivación ganar en el basta y cuando mi
papá llegaba a la casa con una
enciclopedia de carlitos donde sale
snoopy charlie brown era la cosa más
genial y la cosa más interesante
llegó a la primaria y empiezo a poner
como tela de juicio esto es porque es
porque esto maestra porque esto profesor
por qué por qué por qué por qué pero
resulta que él porque en ese momento yo
tenía no era prioridad era prioridad el
porqué del docente del maestro lo que yo
quería aprender pasaba a un segundo
plano y en primer plano estaba lo que mi
maestro me quería enseñar
me preguntaron no no fue así no me
preguntaron
cada vez y poco a poco se fue atenuando
más este deseo de conocer cada vez se
fue atenuando más esta idea de que a mí
me apasiona aprender porque ahora no
puedo aprender lo que quiero sino que
tengo que aprender lo que un adulto
espera que aprenda lo que mi mamá espera
que aprenda lo que mi profesor espera
que aprenda lo que la sociedad espera
que aprenda incluso
se les conoce como aprendizajes
esperados una educación llena de
expectativas llena de expectativas el
docente las tiene las tiene también la
sociedad la familia bueno bueno bueno
bueno bueno y dónde quedan las
expectativas del alumno dónde quedan
pasando el tiempo fue pasando el tiempo
hasta que llegue a secundaria y resulta
que marco no sólo era estudiante también
era hijo también era el marco también
era amigo
y un día estaba sentado en el aula
pensando muchas cosas y frente a mí un
docente preguntándome entonces marco
cuál es la capital de colombia
en ese momento me valía madre de la
capital de colombia no me importaba
porque en ese momento lo único que me
interesaba saber de geografía era la
distancia entre yo y mi papá para
entonces mis padres se habían divorciado
yo llevaba más de un año sin saber algo
de mi papá ya ni siquiera si estaba vivo
o estaba muerto y ahí frente a mí estaba
un profesor indiferente con una
expectativa que yo supiera que bogotá en
la capital de colombia
y yo la única lo único que quería es que
alguien se acercara me diera un abrazo y
me dijera marco todo va a estar bien no
fácil no fue así pasó el tiempo y se
metió en mi cabeza el deseo de ser
profesor el deseo de ser docente de no
ser el docente indiferente del de ser el
docente que conoce las expectativas de
su salud
pasó el tiempo y ese marco estaba ahí
sentado en el aula del salón tratando de
recordar la palabra a bogotá ahora era
el marco que se levantaba todas las
mañanas
se ponía su uniforme
y entonces se iba a la escuela
solo que esta vez no estaba
en la banca del alumno estaba en la
silla del profesor sentado en el
escritorio y ahí había personas había
seres humanos pero resulta que este
marco con uniforme se había olvidado de
eso este marco que se abotona va a su
camisa al salir de su casa para ir a la
escuela se había olvidado de eso
un día llevó a clase
y desde que entró al salón está un
alumno con la mano levantada
pero sí
permite tantito déjame estoy la
explicación y al final plantea esto está
bien seguía con la mano levantada si
quieres bajar la mano ahorita tiene
calambres déjame término y te dé la
palabra para que para atender a duda
dure explicando el tema la clase
ahora
esa era su expectativa de la clase
conocer que pensaba el profesor de la
pelea del canelo habría sido sencillo en
al inicio de la clase llegar y decir qué
pasó
y contestarle y entonces poder seguir
con mi clase le pregunté oye y de que se
atacaba de tratar todo lo que te dije
no sabía no sabía porque lo que a él le
interesaba en ese momento era mi opinión
sobre la pelea del canelo era lo que le
interesaba
todos los días era el mismo ritual
yo pensaba que era el excelente profe el
que iba aún informado el que se apegaba
a un plan de estudios el que llevaba a
su planeación y la seguía al pie de la
letra yo pensaba que ese era el buen
profe pero resulta que era el profe que
se había olvidado que ahí sentados en el
aula tenía seres humanos no solamente
alumnos para entonces mi vida iba de
maravilla
y hacía poco que me había graduado de mi
carrera desde antes de terminar mi
carrera ya daba clases y era docente en
secundaria
todo era genial todo era genial y como
si eso fuera poco sentía que tenía a la
mujer de mis sueños las mañanas llegaban
me subía el carro me sentaba
tomaba el volante y lo único que había
en mi cabeza era voy a ir al salón me
voy a parar frente a los alumnos y voy a
dar lo mejor de mí voy a dar lo mejor de
mí porque mi sueño es que un día esa
mujer que es la mujer de mis sueños esté
frente a mí y me diga si acepto y que
haya unos pequeños que haya unos niños
pequeños ahí que digan el es mi papá él
es mi papá ese era mi sueño todos los
días me levantaba me subía al carro y
pensaba voy a rifar me la voy a dar lo
mejor de mí todos los días todos los
días pero cuando llegaba a la clase se
me olvidaba que tenía alumnos ahí y es
que resulta que mi sueño no tenía nada
que ver con ellos tenía que ver conmigo
y ya el sueño podría ser el mismo si
trabajaba como docente así trabajaba
como arquitecto como licenciado como lo
que fuera
el sueño era exactamente el mismo y era
independiente de dar clases de ser
docente
y resulta que un día algo me hace
recordar que ahí frente a mí hay seres
humanos
un día llega esa mujer de mis sueños y
me dice sabes qué marco se acabó era un
domingo el lunes llegó abro la puerta
del carro
me subo me siento como el volante
y ahora para qué y ahora para qué
el sueño ya no existe
para que ese día llegue al aula y me di
cuenta que no era el único que no tenía
un motivo de estar ahí
me di cuenta que había otros seres
humanos que no tenían un motivo para
estar ahí y que jamás les haya
preguntado qué quieres aprender
qué pasa en tu vida que está pasando
contigo ese día tenía un grupo muy
hostil en la última hora y resulta que
entró al salón y cuando voy entrando al
salón escucho la siguiente frase que
resonó en mi cabeza fuertemente cállate
[ __ ] y expósito no empiezo a hablar
espérense déjenme empiezo la mente
me di cuenta que esa frase no era para
mí era de un alumno que desde la orilla
del salón gritándole a otro que estaba
en esa orilla del salón
me di cuenta que tenía seres humanos
lastimados que tenía personas con el
corazón roto no era el único había otras
personas otros seres humanos ahí con el
corazón roto
el aula el salón de clases es un lugar
mágico pasan cosas interesantísimas ese
día ocurrió un suceso muy especial
mientras se estaba dando la clase se me
ocurrió la siguiente pregunta quién está
completamente seguro de que ahorita va a
poder regresar a su casa y volver a ver
a mamá ya papá ya sus hermanos ya sus
mejores amigos
y todos se quedaron muy serios
pero nunca falta el niño que tiene la
máquina del tiempo y levanta la mano
secundaria levanta la mano tú estás
seguro entonces ya hablan diferente
porque eran de tercero
y ocurrió lo impensable de pronto sonó
mi celular en la escuela en la que
trabajaba estaba completamente prohibido
de los juegos celulares por lo tanto les
pedía permiso a los alumnos me permiten
estar entrando una llamada puedo
contestar dijeron sí profe estáis
entonces
conteste aquella llamada
bueno
no no era lo sorprendente que estuviera
hablando por teléfono con un zapato eso
no era lo sorprendente lo sorprendente
es que en el otro lado de la línea
estaba el ya difunto stephen hawking
como lo escuché y stephen que quiere
saber cómo está aseguró el niño de que
va a ver a su papá ya su mamá la máquina
del tiempo si hay te lo paso
le pase a stephen hawking tuvieron una
conversación muy amena por cierto muy
interesante
y resulta resulta que era oportunidad de
que ellos hablaran en la oportunidad de
que ellos dijeran que era lo que les
interesaba era oportunidad de que ellos
pudieran decir lo que querían decir
resulta que ese día
empezamos con una dinámica
interesantísima de repente pasó una
alumna tomó su celular y le habló a otro
que estaba ya sentado en el salón bueno
quiero pedirte perdón
porque muchas veces está hemos estado en
clase de insultado y yo no sé hasta
donde pueda llegar eso quiero darte
gracias quiero darte gracias porque
cuando ni siquiera he sentido que mi
familia esté allí
has estado tú
pasó a alguien más
hizo una llamada a su abuela que había
perdido no sabes cómo nos hace falta no
sabes cómo nos duele tu partida te amo
abuela
pero hubo una llamada que jamás voy a
olvidar
y una niña hermosa una niña increíble
tomó su teléfono y comenzó
papá
no entiendo por qué te fuiste lo tenías
todo con mi mamá y conmigo porque te
tuviste que ir con otra señora
si algo te tengo que decir ahora que no
te he dicho es que te odio te odio
yo estaba del otro lado del salón
escuchando y le dije te voy a pedir
solamente un favor
antes de terminar esa llamada encuentra
algún motivo para darle gracias a papá
se quedó pensando
no profe no lo hay estás aquí estás viva
quisiera no estarlo
esas fueron palabras quisiera no estar
jamás los voy a olvidar
ese día me di cuenta de lo trascendente
y lo magnífico que es el trabajo del
docente en el aula y más en un lugar
como chihuahua
en mexico en 2015 se registraron 6 mil
285 suicidios a nivel nacional y en
primer lugar esta chihuahua
déjame te digo algo docente déjame te
digo algo alumno
frente a ti hay personas hay seres
humanos rotos lastimados ese día decidí
hacer a un lado el plan de estudios
decidí hacer un un lado la planeación
decidí cerrar los libros pero decidí
algo mejor decidí abrir el corazón
cerramos los libros y abrimos el corazón
no te imaginas lo que pasó después de
eso ya no tenía que decirles a mis
alumnos guarda silencio ellos esperaban
la clase ansiosos para aprender ahora si
lo que yo quería enseñarles porque ya
era tiempo de que ellos hablaran lo que
quisieran había llegado el momento en el
que podía enseñar lo que yo quería
después de eso ocurrió un fenómeno
interesantísimo era mi última clase con
un tercero de secundaria y cuando me
despedía de la clase hacían una fila en
el escritorio
con los brazos abiertos uno a uno iban a
dar un abrazo porque hay una carencia de
afectividad y una carencia de amor en
nuestras aulas ese día me di cuenta que
es más fácil educar había abriendo un
par de brazos que un millón de libros
gracias
[Aplausos]